Sex is the foundation of life.
It is at the root of our nature and our lives
are in constant motion towards it.
Every component of life works to ensure the
survival and advancement of life itself.
Sex is arguably the most powerful component
as it is the means in which life perpetuates
and fights for the collective state of existence.
But what implications does the force of sex
have on our conscious and human experience
of life?
As humans, we seek and require more than just
physical, sexual relationships.
We want depth and connection.
We want love.
But while we are all aware of this and hope
to fulfill our conscious goals of connection
and love, the biological survival force of
sex works to deprives us of these goals.
This force controls our unconscious minds
and pushes us towards sex with lots of strangers,
and away from genuine connection and intimacy.
The urge and curiosity for sexual adventure
and variety is constantly lingering inside
of us, prodding for attention.
So how should we deal with it?
If we break our sexuality down, we can separate
its goals into two categories.
Love and lust.
Love being our conscious goal.
And lust being our unconscious biological
one.
We want to satisfy both… and we can.
But only when a particular order and process
is followed.
Otherwise, we will constantly run back and
forth between the two and never truly achieve
either.
Lust comes easier than love, but that does
not make it more important.
Lust is hollow when it is not filled by love.
Lust is needy and greedy.
It wants all of our attention and cares for
nothing other than itself.
When we chase lust, we are forced to neglect
love.
When we succumb to lust, we become attracted
to everyone and as a result, not REALLY anyone.
We will never find love through lust.
We may pretend that we have, but we would
be lying to our self.
Lust almost always alludes to feelings of
love, but does not always ensure it.
The yearning of survival and reproduction
that drives us to want to have sex with as
many people as possible relies on the circularity
of sex; anticipation-action-pleasure-emptiness-repeat.
And somewhere within this cycle, we are expecting
to find love.
But it is not there.
Lust does not care about love or the various
aspirations of humankind.
Confusing lust with love is why there is often
so much conflict and failure in relationships
and marriages.
As humans, we are an overpopulated species.
So maintaining existence is no longer the
issue at hand.
Therefore, our sexual nature warrants partially
useless results.
As willful beings, we have the power to examine
and understand this and determine how we wish
to recalibrate our actions to better fit a
balanced and fulfilling life.
The real problem humanity is facing is not
population or survival.
It is lack of love.
Lack of connection.
Lack of happiness.
The only way to love is through love itself.
Love comes first.
You must open yourself up to the love that
you posses.
It is something within us all that is beyond
objectification.
By embracing the unity between yourself and
the wrest of the world, love blossoms within
you.
Love in a lustful and romantic sense may fleet,
but love in the sense of connection does not.
As chemicals fluctuate in the brain and factors
of the world push and pull you out of romance,
you can still remain constantly with love.
When you maintain this, your love will manifest
into relationships that are strong and meaningful.
By seeking love through lust, you miss out
on love.
But by seeking lust through love, you become
able to profoundly enjoy both.